that's a really good point I think it's
better it doesn't seem that bad there's
a should I even see if she's texted
nation I pull my phone out you know I've
been listening to us oh my god I'm not
listening to this story
okay oh my God my brain is going a mile
a minute run over it okay
nod your head make eye contact as a mile
a minute sounds much faster than sixty
miles an hour
but those are kind of just the same
thing alright slow your brain down slow
this whole thing down be snail blow my
god he's looking at me now asking me
questions make eye contact shake your
head what are snails even trying to do
yeah okay so we're in Arizona Arizona
everything what the [ __ ] cares about
Arizona does this day there is that no
it's shitty it's like think I'm a bad
friend for not listening in am i bad
friend but we will know yeah no yeah no
no you're digging a hole and we were
really hungry and pretend like you know
what he's talking about with some key
words and you'll get right back in there
say something smart to say something
intelligent say something you haven't
work no yeah right yeah
hey I just realized now that cell phones
are becoming more and more waterproof
it's gonna be easier and easier to push
people in the pool without being the
dick at the party
you